est-ce qu'il y a ici un sol
parlementaire qui peut lever la main et
dire j'ai trop de médecins généralistes
dans mon département enlevez-moi des
médecins parce qu'à la fin c'est ça qui
va se produire madame la Présidente
c'est un jeu à somme nul on va diplômé
des médecins on va les enlever dans des
territoires pour espérer les arrêts
attribuer dans d'autres il n'iront
patient installer et à la fin ce qui
voteront pour Hero expliquait dans leur
territoire pourquoi il y aura moins de
médecins
[Musique]
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté
merci de bien vouloir respirer
nous proposons ce n'est pas d'affecter
les médecins ici ou là j'ai entendu des
choses qui étaient parfaitement fausses
nous disons à nos médecins
n'allez plus vous installer là où les
besoins de soins sont déjà pourvus mais
allez vous installer où vous voudrez
ailleurs là où les besoins de santé ne
sont pas pourvus là où vos patients vous
attendent ça n'est pas de la coercition
ça n'est pas envoyé des internes dans
les territoires sudotés c'est pas cela
ce que nous disons c'est là où la
densité est suffisante c'est un départ
plats à plaques c'est très simple il y a
1m qui parle à la retraite c'est un
autre qui arrive donc on peut pas me
faire la musique de dire cette zone là
vous allez la rendre soudance c'est pas
vrai on reste au même niveau alors oui
je suis pas contre effectivement qu'on
se comprenne le temps et avec les
professionnels pour inventer un système
qui permet et bien d'assurer une
meilleure répartition des forces
médicales dans le territoire mais
l'enjeu d'ici là et c'est là-dessus que
je voudrais insister l'enjeu de d'ici là
contenu de la des difficultés
démographiques c'est de garder avec nous
nos soignants nous en avons de moins en
moins je l'ai expliqué j'ai donné les
chiffres si nous perdons nos soignants
alors nous aurons pas réussi
effectivement à améliorer l'accès aux
soins des Français loin d'améliorer la
situation ces amendements s'ils sont
votés vont dégrader l'offre de soins
tout d'abord par des refus
d'installation c'est déjà le cas ça va
s'accentuer dès demain des départs en
retraite qui vont s'accentuer alors que
notre objectif est justement de garder
ses médecins plus longtemps en activité
des décongestionnements qui vont créer
ce que personne ne souhaite à savoir
cette médecine à deux vitesses
les médecins ne sont pas captifs encore
moins les médecins généralistes ils vont
se diriger vers d'autres professions et
ils ont la possibilité de le faire à
l'issue de leur
spécialité de médecine générale mais
également avant vous le savez
certainement il y a ce qu'on appelle le
droit aux remords donc des jeunes qui
sont déjà inscrits en médecine générale
vont s'en aller dès demain pour une
autre spécialité et puis je ne parle
même pas de l'étranger qui fait les yeux
doux à nos médecins parce qu'ils sont
particulièrement bien formés